You've got two sons. I think we've got a picture of you here just after you gave birth
No, that's Charlie he's now almost Three. He's two and a half and that's us.
We have now two; we have River Joe who's one and he's two and a half.
Is it Charlie who's like a sort of little mini-me?
Yeah a little bit a little bit. I see you know, you start you say things and then they they repeat them
He says a couple of things that I say. My dad, and this is probably a regionalism, used to say
asses and elbows meaning
We'd be in the kitchen washing pots and pans. And if I if I
participated I'd be kind of
Mm-hmm, and you come on let's really get in there! Asses and elbows!
So now Charlie, I'm often in charge of seeing him brush his teeth and teaching him that that takes a while
so he kind of you know does a little bit of this and I go come on asses and elbows and
He says it's fun to hear him say asses and elbows.
And then the other day I heard him say... I guess I said it
He said oh, yeah, I said you like those pancakes. He said "Yeah, never in my whole life"
have I had pancakes this good
[Audience laughing]
I said "What'd you say?" Yes! Your young life!
Your long life, two and a half.
In over three and a half years!
Chris, your a son seems remarkably unimpressed by your career.
Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, he really couldn't care less.
There's the thing that he doesn't believe you're the real deal.
Yeah, I mean he's now, you know fi-, he'll say he's five and three-quarters and he and he went to Universal
the other day, Universal Studios in LA.
Theme park, had a good time and came back and he said hey Dad. Guess what today?
I saw the real Owen
Like, there's this guy at a universal who dresses up like my character from the movie
And the dinosaurs come out
He like does this thing and the kids he's like "no, I saw the real one dad."
I was like "Yeah, alright!"
I mean, he's putting the work in. He's there every day.
Yeah, right, yeah! It's true! Actually, yeah.
The whole year he's there like:
You obviously, you know you you have your parenting rules and all that
But apparently that was it the parenting rules change if you go fishing
Yes, that's right. That's right. We have a
I have a farm up in Washington State and on this farm is a lake and and it's
we fish a lot for bass on this Lake my son and I and
I had this rule with my old man and and I have it with my son which is when you're fishing
You can swear. You can just swear when you're fishing. It's just the guys
Go ahead and let loose and so we're out fishing
He catches a fish and I'm trying to get him to take a picture with the fish before we let it go and it flops
Out of his hands and and these bass have these little spines on the on their back and the fin pokes them in the hand
Falls in the water. He starts to cry and he's like, oh ho and I said, hey buddy, are you
All right you all right. He said Oh dad. I'm about to swear
Hey, you know, you know the rules and he goes "That bass, that bass is stupid!"
You know, I think we say hey don't call someone call someone stupid, that's bad!
You shouldn't say that. And he continues to cry, "D'you feel better?"
he said "a little bit, stupid, stupid bass" and I was like
"All right, buddy. Yeah, you know now's the time get it out" and he goes
"Stupid bass is a fucking pussy!"